my day I'm gonna leave my dick alone I
know people that don't whatever GQ is
black bear we're gonna check out some of
my eat I was gonna go for the sleep
thing and then I quit really mind my
sleeve career was ended I started like
most people on my arm that's why I have
like crazy I was like 14 15 and I have
like a flying pig over here like when
pigs fly I thought oh that's cool so I
was like let's do a cityscape pigs
flying it says imagine here like like
the Beatles there's Earth John Lennon
song there's a cloud with a pirate patch
on like it just makes no sense so I've
been getting tattooed for like I don't
know I'm 28 now my parents always just
we're just like oh man like nothing
shocked I'm at that point I think I
already had like like lip rings and like
ridiculous clothes and like I would just
would not conform to any you know super
edgy that's really bad my plan is to
actually start blasting big black
tattoos over it like different ones
because it's it's faded over the years
enough to where I can do that I think
but who knows maybe the pig will survive
I have one big tattoo starts here I
don't know
hundreds in the I'm probably in the high
hundreds I think I think I I think I
lost count when I started moving to my
hands and neck then it's like then it's
over I have this style of tattooing
where I don't like like sleeve work as
much for me personally I like it on
other people certain people it looks
really cool like the rock but for me I
like I like almost like the Amy
Winehouse style of just like tattoos
everywhere but I've always loved hair
tattoos I tell people this all the time
that if I can go back and not get one
eye what
have any but I'm like an all-or-nothing
person and that's just how I am with
everything so that's just kind of yeah
that's kind of how it happened it's a
product of like my brain is how I look
yeah I have some good ones where the
boom like this is good I have a t-mobile
Sidekick right here it's a good one logo
for Alkaline Trio punk rock band this
one Halsey drawn me at my house and I
got it tattooed the next day they all
have like a cool story I have this one
business in the front and the party in
the back drink bleach 13 because I got
on Friday 13th so it was like free
matching tattoos like four of my friends
a [ __ ] here I got this one in New
York when I did the Gucci Ghost party I
performed it for Fashion Week so trouble
and rude rude this and a bunch of Gucci
stuff on me this is like real Gucci skin
kind of cool thing I kind of just tell
the people I like I let people who are
good at things do with it like because I
can't like that great my house at home
like I let the interior designer do that
you know like because I've tried it
before my ways are not always awesome so
lucky I've let people draw them out I
just tell my ideas and then sometimes
I'll doodle but it's just like horrible
so I'll just stick to music for now yeah
there's there's so many stories man
that's my favorite part about getting
tattoos is that I can look at them and
think about like where I was they're
like why it was funny some of them are
funny some are serious but mainly mainly
I have a bunch of [ __ ] on my body
[Music]
I do
shout out Kelly at teen Hearts tattoos
he does everything from the neck down
he's done my whole torso and everything
like that he's just as crazy as me I
think at least like artistically and
he's down for like any crazy idea that I
have
tumblr I think he was like a real thing
it was like photoshopped and I was like
I want the back it was a cover-up
because I tried to get the house from up
with the balloons and it just looked
really horrible so we needed something
big and black to cover it up which is
awesome three-eyed there's a giant cry
for help here I did it myself
so that's like special there's just
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on I did
the 27 grave myself on my 27th birthday
like five of my friends we did it at my
house oh this is cool nice lovely [ __ ]
yeah I got an internet troll here too it
was cool not like I'm a cyber bully or
anything because that's kind of how
that's taken sometimes but but I just
I'm like an Internet I'm a product of
the internet like if it weren't for the
Internet I wouldn't even be sitting here
right now for him for SoundCloud look
like that I've kind of trolled my way
into being a millionaire bear trap here
it's the name of my record label bear
trap sound so actually just fit on the
finger that's figured why not do that
est 1990 that's what I was born mom and
dad these are kind of like sticking
pokes - I have the all-seeing eye like
gods
you know the third eye treasure chest
it's kind of busted that thing kids are
really going OD right now and not
tattooing anywhere else and then I think
in like tattoo culture to start on your
neck and hands and face before you have
tattoos everywhere else and you're kind
of running out of space it's kind of
like looked down upon at least like a
testicle a tattoo culture but live your
life if you want to tattoo your face
like just remember it's like they're for
I'm not sure which side I'm looking at
but I think there's a bear paw here so
the bear paws because I black bear which
is pretty cool and then over here is
Flagler Beach Florida where where I grew
up is I mean the compass traditionally
is like a nautical cool thing just to
add but but I don't know leads me home
deaths always following me it was kind
of like a morbid tattoo but I think it's
cool it's traditional it's awesome I
think there's a town sign here a bear
trap lover boy here I think the guy who
did it
his whole brand is like loverboy and all
this stuff so it was like really an
honor to get Alex Miller to write lover
boy here on my back I have the serenity
prayer tattooed really big on my friend
Alex Miller who also did my lover boy
here he's one of my favorite prayers
it's super deep and super simple and
great yes I do I got I got it during the
music video shoot for my song hi one
time it was it's kind of like it's
awesome because it's like there forever
and it's like when I shot that video I
did it on a picnic table and like the on
the side of like some pole that the kids
were skating and stuff it was like
really cool I was just like Broca crazy
you went crazy no we actually the way we
do it is we set it up we take a picture
of my body and we put it in Photoshop
and we actually put them on first so
everything yeah the way that you see it
is all was meant to be even though it
doesn't just like it's supposed to be at
all it's just dead to you which is
pretty cool that's one of the things
that we photoshopped as well we just put
it on there it's funny because you can
see it in my newest album cover on
anonymous
you can see the it says dead which is
really cool it's kind of like an
underlying theme of black bear I think I
drink too much right here where I have a
scar from a surgery I had from
pancreatitis from actually drinking too
much it was a it was a horrible long
three months like in the hospital like
it was I was fighting for life so I
don't drink anymore in three years now I
haven't trained but yeah so I had that
in the devil's hand going through the
scar here the scar filled up really
nicely thank God
yeah I had a Coco Capitan the girl who
wrote the on the Gucci Bags
I don't know what the Gucci bag says but
I know mine says what is this future
going to do with us I think the Gucci
bag said what are we going to do with
all this future it's really cool that I
have like a special coco kappa time from
go to yeah yeah this is my friend boogie
and so it's a two hands shaking but it's
also like a nice equality tattoo of just
like black dude white dude you know
we're friend we're homies you know
thanks for listening to my horrible
stories about my horrible tattoos I'm
black bear I'll be coming back soon
Thank You GQ